Turkish president receipt erdogan has
been sworn in for a third term his two
decades in power have now been extended
by another five years his new cabinet
includes a former International Banker
will be the new Finance Minister some
say his appointment signals a shift away
from unconventional economic policies
Osama bin Javed reports from Ankara
a historic third decade in power
as president erdogan begins his third
term as president the day's events began
with the oath of office at the Grand
National Assembly which predates the
Republic
erdogan made it a point to pay his
respects to the founder of the Turkish
Republic Mustafa Kamal some see it as
the beginning of a healing process for a
politically divided nation
for the next five years we will continue
to work hard to realize our vision of
the century of turkey to protect the
Eternal Brotherhood of our nation
officials from 78 countries including
heads of state and prime ministers
attended the ceremony among them the
Secretary General of NATO where turkey
plays an important role president
erdogan acknowledged the challenges his
government faces
as we enter the century of turkey our
goal is to be among the top 10 economies
in order to do this we will produce
value-added Goods become an energy Hub
and invite the world's Financial parties
into Istanbul we were facing a polarized
World following the Ukraine war and
turkey as mediation solved the ensuing
food crisis everyone will benefit from
this balanced approach Not Just Turkey
the economy Remains the hot topic of
conversation in Turkey High inflation a
weak currency and the highest current
account deficit in decades are all
Mammoth tasks but after a bitter
campaign everyone pushed for Unity and
healing
let's put aside the resentments from the
election period if there is resentment
let's find a way to make peace let's all
work together for the construction of
the century of Turkey
and to implement that Vision president
erdogan has chosen his most trusted
people's Treasury and Finance Minister
he's an economist and served as Deputy
Prime Minister from 2015 to 2018.
hakan fidan is foreign minister now he
was previously the Turkish intelligence
Chief and Eli erlikaya has been
appointed interior Minister he was the
former Governor of Istanbul
is the new defense minister he was the
head of the Armed Forces
the third decade in power is going to be
the biggest test yet for president
erdogan overcoming internal and external
challenges is where himself and his
newly appointed cabinet will have to
prove their
medals at the presidential Palace Ankara
well Zia morale is from the European
leadership Network he explained the
background to erdogan's new cabinet
appointments well I mean if the Rolo
descent to a bank and its Governor is to
return to what it has always been which
is more independent aside from the
government policies
um then it would be a really welcome
move and the possible candidate that has
been raised publicly at this moment is
somebody who's received a PhD from
Princeton but also as an investment
background abroad as well in the United
States so these are very positive
signals we will wait to see obviously
appointments are one thing and the other
thing is whether president erdogan is
actually going to give them but what is
really interesting about all these
appointments is when you take all of
them together from foreign minister to
defense minister to even interior
Minister these are all to do is that
erdogan can count on to keep everything
so they then enter into polamics or
cause any political Mischief if you like
I think the message from all of this for
the next 10 months and if not for the
next few years is going to be that add
one is focusing on strengthening against
political position addressing some of
the concerns that almost cost him this
election and pursue his vision for this
new century of the Republic and he's
giving all these key portfolios to
people that he trusts to deliver